hi i'm kami and i'm kelly and today we
are making our aunt gussie's pound cake
the reason why this recipe is so popular
in our family is just because it's so
easy
you don't have to preheat the oven it's
a technique yeah and i don't know why
but it's just like this is how you do it
yeah
it's just like been around forever and
everybody makes it yeah yeah you anta
my mother yeah everybody and it's super
easy to whip out like you have guests
coming over it's just like okay you can
make this in like a short amount of time
it looks like it took a lot of time and
it really doesn't and it's kind of
foolproof
but i think
for us it's got that emily tie so when i
make it i think about my mother and i
think about aunt dusty it's sort of like
keeping her alive and the memory of her
and the special ties with her through
this pound cake
just stuff in your face just stuff in
your face
you know ankasie was sort of like a
trailblazer she's never married which
was like a
kind of thing at that time and she did
things her way including
baking
she was a very strong figure especially
a time when maybe women of color were
not viewed in that way and on gussie you
see lived with her sister on anna in
youngstown ohio and we would go
every year
to visit them like stepping back in time
they used to set the table for every
meal they ironed their sheets they made
their own jam they made everything it
does present a time to love on each
other a little bit you know by lancer
really good
right mm-hmm
[Music]